see youtubers is Charlie so you guys
have been asking me about the Celestials
Easter egg and the Thor preview from a
while ago and about the trailer so I'm
gonna explain what's going on if you're
new to the channel I do Marvel and DC
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's even a spider-man
giveaway going on I'll explain at the
end of the video but if you didn't spot
it I know a lot of you did you were
asking me about this this armor here
that this person is wearing sitting next
to Valkyrie in this store Ragnarok
preview looks just like saran the tester
one of Marvel's Celestials now each of
the Celestials is about 2,000 feet tall
so obviously this is probably not the
actual celestial himself but we know
they exist in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as we saw during guardians of
the galaxy when the collector was
explaining the history of the infinity
gems so this celestial is Isan the
searcher he's the person that searches
for new planets with the orb to take
down in the context of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but they were
introduced to the comics by Jack Kirby
as this ancient race that dates back to
the beginning of the universe
technically they're not the first beings
in the universe that's supposed to be
Galactus but in the eternal comic book
they were described as this ancient race
that was just all-powerful till another
group came along in deltas giant
celestial armor called a God killer to
take them down it was featured during
the Ironman run when he went to join the
guardians of the galaxy so if you didn't
need that it happened around the time
the first guardians movie came out is
really cool it's the most powerful armor
that he's ever worn with the exception
of the time that he wore the Infinity
Gauntlet but it's just designed to give
the where the powers of a celestial so
that you can kill other Celestials so
way back in the ancient history of their
race that's what happened and that's why
there's not that many of them around the
other big celestial is actually nowhere
which is just the name of the place they
gave to the inside hollowed out head of
a dead celestial it's a collector and
all these people have been mining for
resources so we don't actually know the
name of this celestial the ones that are
still around you just don't hear about a
lot because they're not ready to use
them in the movies in a big way in the
main reason for that is because they're
crazy opie they come into play during
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline even
Galactus standing there with them is not
enough to challenge Thanos with
the power of the Infinity Gauntlet so
because they're trying to keep these
movies as grounded as possible while
still allowing them to get pretty crazy
you only see shades of Celestials so
that's where I ran the tester comes in
here he's the one that goes around
judging different species to see if
they're ready for Celestials genetic
testing they just conduct a lot of
testing they experiment a lot in
bringing it back around to guardians of
the galaxy and egos living planet here's
a really deep cut so ego the Living
Planet was born so to speak in the black
galaxy which is just this weird place in
space made up of organic matter that's
where Thor first encountered him way
back in the old Thor comics later we
find out that the black galaxy itself is
just an experiment concocted by the
Celestials so effectively ego the Living
Planet was born based on a Celestials
experiment but I'm not expecting the
movie to push too deep into that he's
only meant to be this ancient figure in
the history of the galaxy sort of like
the ancient enemy slash protagonist
antagonist depending on who you talked
to and he's one of the elders of the
universe in addition to the collector
and the Grandmaster who's in Thor
Ragnarok so bringing it back around to
Thor Ragnarok you have this bar on Sekar
where the Grandmaster holds these games
wouldn't it be fitting for a celestial
to be hanging out with one of the elders
of the universe so really this is just
an easter egg level but you'll continue
to see Celestials pop up in ways like
this but you might not see physical
Celestials in present day going up
against the heroes Isan the searcher
style wielding one of the Infinity
stones but you'll probably spot things
in the background there will be nods to
them like they want you to remember
they're still around and because door
Ragnarok is visually really crazy
they're invoking a lot of crazy Jack
Kirby stuff so if you're a big fan of
that kind of storytelling read the
Eternals comic book or you can read the
new Ultimates to comic book where they
get into really crazy cosmic concepts in
fact during that we learn where all the
Celestials have been hiding they've been
hiding at the edge of space because the
beyonders started to kill all of them
during the secret wars art so during
time runs out the Beyonder start
destroying everything that is their
creation the multiverse starts
collapsing on itself so all the
Celestials
we're out of here and they all bail to
the edge of reality like the edge of
what is known and just hide out until
they show up during this Ultimates comic
book where the cosmic entity logos which
is the fusion of Lord chaos master order
and the in-betweener just obliterates
them all so right now in the comics
there's a lot of crazy stuff going on if
you like that cosmic level storytelling
check that out it's stuff that they're
probably never going to touch in the
movies we might even get to see Thor
bite someone like this now we know he's
going to be fighting Hulk because of the
planet whole comic book stuff they're
doing but in the comics Odin actually
thought Saran the tester and the other
Celestials he had to infuse the
destroyer armor with his Odin force it
became this thing called the you know
mine in the Celestials just obliterated
it they melted the destroyer down they
were so powerful so we might actually
get to see a version of this happen on
screen but let me know how do you want
them to use the Celestials in the movies
going forward keeping in mind that the
most powerful beings that we've seen so
far have been Dormammu and Thanos with
the Infinity Gauntlet we've done the T's
for that but beyond that I think they're
trying to keep all the heroes from
getting Opie and they want to balance
the scale so in civil war it's meant to
be people versus people so that their
stakes they could possibly die in thor
ragnarok it's going to be God versus God
so you have two people of relatively
equal power although technically the
Hulk is stronger but they are referring
to him as a God on this planet so what
I'll do for my next door Ragnarok video
is I'll explain why it is the Thor
fights Hulk because you'd have to have
some really big incentive to have Thor
fight one of his friends so there's a
really good reason why that happens and
why they get so into it for everybody
asking about the trailer they've started
posting more and more on the Thor social
the people behind the movie the director
Chris Hemsworth have been active on
social a lot more lately so they're
ramping up for a trail of reveal but
because guardians is getting ready to
come out they'll probably just attach it
to that so that's coming out the fifth
in the United States and North America
so expect a lot of Thor's stuff to be
happening around that week so we might
get like a small teaser if they don't
drop the big bull trailer so just a
couple more weeks but usually before
that happens they start posting
more behind-the-scenes stuff so it's
sort of like a slow ramping up to
dropping a giant trailer bomb on
everyone in related cosmic news I know a
lot of you are asking about Starhawk
during guardians of the galaxy to that
rumor was supposedly debunked so I'm not
planning on doing a video about it but
leave all your requests for a Guardians
spider-man
Marvel videos in the comments below
anything you guys want we still have a
little while before guardians comes out
so there'll be more Guardian stuff
happening in the next couple weeks but
there is a new round of the Spider Man
action figure giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so what's going to
happen next is is there'll be some new
Game of Thrones and I'm complaining I'm
doing a Teen Titans Judas contract
review so if you guys want me to do a
video for that just let me know in the
comments but you can click here for a
big defenders interview where he talks
about infinity war and you can click
here for that Thor Ragnarok preview
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video